[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal live aus
Kiew mit Marietta Slomka
guten Abend aus Kiew schaut auf diese
Stadt einst verdammt Berlin gemeint
heute blickt die Welt zumindest die
westliche auf die Hauptstadt der Ukraine
am Vorabend des Jahrestages in dem die
Ukraine um ihre nackte Existenz kämpft
in dem es aber auch um ein systemkampf
und die Sicherheit in Europa geht
wir stehen hier auf einer Terrasse im
Stadtteil podil das ist ein besonders
bei jungen Leuten beliebtes ausgeführte
und die haben wir am Abend ein paar
Stimmen eingefangen
vor einem Jahr haben wir nicht glauben
können was passiert doch in einer
modernen Welt leben es war komplett zu
real
aber wir sind bereit bis zum Ende für
unsere Unabhängigkeit zu kämpfen
wir sind uns sicher wir sind richtige
Europäer wir sind Teil der zivilisierten
Welt das sind unsere ureigenen Werte
ist heute Abend fast schon geschwänzte
still das liegt nicht nur an der
Ausgangssperre die ganzen letzten Tage
sind eher ruhig verlaufen hier und da
ein kurzer Luftalarm das bringt in
dieser Stadt aber niemanden aus der
Fassung viele tierverfürchten aber dass
es zu ruhig war dass da noch was kommt
die eigentlichen Kämpfe toben aber ja in
anderen Gebieten der Ukraine vor allem
im Osten in bachmut oder ein Hackes die
zweitgrößte Stadt der Ukraine stand auch
heute wieder unter schweren Beschuss
Katrin Eugendorf war in der Region um
Hackes mit Soldaten unterwegs
im Grenzgebiet Soldaten der ukrainischen
Territorialverteidigung fahren voraus
nur mit ihnen können wir an die
Frontlinie ein Labyrinth von
Schützengräben durchzieht die Landschaft
einen Kilometer von hier entfernt stehen
die russischen Truppen die Soldaten
wollen nicht lange auf dem freien Feld
stehen gerade erst am Morgen wurden sie
beschossen ich folge ihnen hinunter zu
ihrem überwachungsposten von hier aus
überblicken Sie das Gebiet
die Russen stehen dahinter diesen Hügeln
das ist die staatliche Grenzlinie der
Ukraine
Ukraine das heißt sie sehen hier was
wir sehen ihre Bewegungen wo
raketenstaaten die Harke treffen
russland ist der Kommandant der Einheit
sie alle sind Zivilisten und haben sich
freiwillig gemeldet um zu kämpfen im
September haben sie die russischen
Soldaten aus den umliegenden Dörfern
vertrieben jetzt sollen sie hier die
Grenze sichern um einen russischen
Vorstoß aufzuhalten haben sie nur
Maschinengewehre
sie kommen hier hin sie versuchen es sie
versuchen zu prüfen ob wir Ihnen
Widerstand leisten
ob wir bereit sind sie zurückzuschlagen
könnte ja sein dass hier niemand steht
an diesem Tag das ist spürbar sind die
Männer nervös auch sie rechnen damit das
Russland jetzt am Jahrestag des
Kriegsbeginns verstärkt angreift am
Morgen erst wurde hakit gleich mehrfach
beschossen welche Perspektive sehen Sie
nach einem Jahr Krieg
nur Sieg
wir müssen den Feind über die
Grenzlinien zurücktreiben wann das ist
ich weiß es nicht es hängt von den
Entscheidungen unserer Führung ab oder
der Hilfe des Westens die brauchen wir
um uns zu schützen
[Musik]
obwohl es nicht in ihrer Hand liegt die
Einheit von Russland ist entschlossen zu
kämpfen egal wie lange der Krieg noch
dauert
wir sind Teil der zivilisierten Welt
sagte vorhin ein Mann hier auf der
Straße und jetzt sind wir aber erstmal
mit Katrin Eigendorf geschaltet ja hat
das geklappt wunderbar Katrin in rakev
diese das was du da jetzt im Osten
beobachten kannst nicht nur in hakiff
ist das jetzt diese angekündigte
russische Offensive
dass ein differenziertes Bild was ich
hier ergibt hakef ist in den letzten
Tagen verstärkt wieder angegriffen
worden an dem Tag als wir mit der
Territorialverteidigung mit den Soldaten
gedreht haben mussten wir den Dreh sogar
verschieben weil die Stadt gleich
viermal angegriffen wurde und das ist
schon eine Situation die sich von der in
den Wochen davor deutlich unterscheidet
von einer großen Angriffswelle mit der
man hier gerechnet hat kann man
allerdings im Moment noch nicht sprechen
allerdings ist die Stimmung hier sehr
sehr angespannt die Menschen rechnen
doch noch damit das morgen eben am 24
dem Tag des
Kriegsbeginns hier ist doch noch mal zu
einer verstärkten Angriffswelle kommen
kann besonders schlimm wird im Moment in
der Region um bachmut gekämpft es hat
heute mehrere Angriffe auch auf die
Stadt kubians gegeben und wir haben hier
mit Soldaten einer Einheit gesprochen
die jetzt in Kürze dorthin verlegt
werden soll und die sagen es ist
wirklich so dass dort dringend Nachschub
gebraucht wird dass dort einfach nicht
mehr genug Soldaten sind und
anscheinend will die Ukraine zumindest
in den kommenden Tagen daran festhalten
bachmut zu verteidigen auch wenn die
Situation dort sehr sehr schlimm ist und
möglicherweise dann erst eben nach dem
Jahrestag bachmut vielleicht aufgeben
das ist jetzt im Moment die Situation
hier im Osten der Ukraine
Dankeschön Katrin nach rakif
und dann kommen wir noch mal zurück auf
das was den Mann vorhin in unserer
Sendung kam am Anfang gesagt hat nämlich
wir sind Teil der zivilisierten Welt das
sagte er ja bei dieser straßenfrage und
das Betonen Ukrainer immer wieder wir
gehören zu euch zu Europa und wir
verteidigen hier nicht nur uns sondern
auch eure Sicherheit und eure Werte und
der Zivilisationsbruch den Russland darf
ukrainischen Boden begeht der wurde erst
eigentlich nach den ersten Kriegswochen
an seinem ganzen Ausmaß fassbar als es
den Ukrainern gelangen besetzte Gebiete
zu befreien und dadurch ans Tageslicht
kam mit welch blanker Barbarei Putins
Armee dort gewütet hatte
ortsnah wie Mutter oder irrtin haben
sich ins weltgedächtnis eingegraben ich
habe mich in Oppin mit einer jungen Frau
getroffen deren Leben in Trümmern liegt
die Brücke von irpi in den ersten
Kriegswochen flogen hier tausende
Menschen über den Fluss während sie
geschossen wurden
Irina moga
die Gebiete da hinten hatten die Russen
schon besetzt
und hier hatten sie ihre Scharfschützen
Irina 70-Jährige Mutter wurde auf einer
Trage über ein wackligen Holzsteg
getragen jetzt mein Marcel
Bilder die um die Welt ging
dieser Steg hat uns zwar gerettet aber
zugleich war das hier der Ort an dem man
sein ganzes Leben hinter sich liest alle
unsere Hoffnungen alle Träume alles was
vorher war
die beiden Vororte die zum Inbegriff der
Hölle wurden der Barbarei Zerstörung
Folter Vergewaltigung ganze Familien
erschossen ihre Leichen verbrannt oder
mit Panzern überrollt
ehrlich gesagt ich fühle nur noch Hass
natürlich wir wissen wir uns das angetan
hat und ich ich fühle nur noch Hass
war beliebt bei jungen Familien die
Immobilienpreise günstiger als in Kiew
aber für Pendler nah genug an der
Hauptstadt viel Grün frische Luft gute
Häuser
bis die Russen kam
in diesem Wohnblock ist Irina
aufgewachsen das mit eigenen Augen zu
sehen ist noch mal ganz anders als auf
Fernsehbildern
wir liegen alle meine
Kindheitserinnerungen wie wir
Nachbarskinder hier immer alle zusammen
spielten Fußball verstecken
jeder kannte jeden jetzt kann hier
eigentlich niemand mehr wohnen nur ein
paar alte Nachbarinnen sind geblieben
die nicht wissen wohin
die Wohnung ihrer Mutter ist komplett
zerstört
wie altes Kinderzimmer die Küche in der
sie so gerne zusammen saßen
ihre Mutter war Bibliothekarin die
beliebten Bücher nur noch Asche
nur eine Lampe ist heil geblieben als
meine Mutter das sah sagte sie
ausgerechnet die die mochte ich
eigentlich nie
doch das bisher schlimmste war der Tag
als sie mit einem Bekannten über eine
Straße lief und neben ihnen etwas
explodiert wahrscheinlich eine Granate
Irina wurde verletzt eine Kopfwunde und
das Trommelfell gerissen aber der
Nachbar starb vor ihren Augen schwerst
verstümmelt
zu sehen wie ein Mensch innerhalb von
einer Sekunde auf die andere tot ist das
war so beängstigend
niemand sagt Irina sollte so etwas
erleben müssen sie hat sich als
Freiwillige bei der Armee gemeldet im
Rekrutierungsbüro von irpin
Irena arbeitete in früher in der
Marketingabteilung eines Kunststoff
Herstellers ihre ganze Freizeit wütete
sie einer Tierschutzorganisation in
meinem Gespräch mit ihr sagte sie immer
wieder so ist Krieg das musste ich auch
erst lernen aber jetzt weiß ich was das
ist welche gewaltige Traumatisierungen
damit einhergehen das war eines der
Themen über die ich mit der First Lady
der Ukraine gesprochen habe mit Elena
zum Interview mit der First Lady bin ich
in den Präsidentenpalast geladen das ist
auch der Ort an dem sie ihren Mann
trifft oft bekommen Sie ihn aber nicht
zu Gesicht sagt sie
lenska ich bin natürlich jetzt neu hier
in Kiew aber schon in der kurzen Zeit in
der ich hier bin habe ich gemerkt dass
einerseits und mit Ukrainern und
Ukrainerinnen spricht alle sagen unser
kampfeswelle ist ist ungebrochen aber
gleichzeitig eben auch eine große
Erschöpfung da ist
ein Stress nach einem Jahr also wie geht
Ihnen das
Video natürlich ich bin ja ein Teil
unserer Gesellschaft genauso wie meine
Familie wir sind alle erschöpft wir
verausgaben uns aber wir können und
dürfen nicht stehen bleiben denn davon
hängt unsere Rettung ab
wir kämpfen für unser Leben für das
Leben unseres Landes deshalb spreche ich
lieber nicht über Erschöpfung sondern
über Hoffnung
wir glauben an den Sieg denn wissen sie
in den Märchen siegt immer das Gute über
das Böse und wir wissen dass das Gute an
unserer Seite ist wir haben niemanden
überfallen wir hatten auch nie solche
Absichten wir wollen Frieden und wir
werden uns ihn auch erkämpfen ja im
Märchen gewinnt immer das Gute aber
manchmal eben auch in der Realität das
Böse und das braucht eine große
Unterstützung dafür damit in diesem Fall
eben das Böse wie sie sagen nicht
gewinnt wie dankbar sind sie denn
Vereinigten Staaten für die
Unterstützung die es jetzt gerade auch
in diesen Tagen gibt
wir sind all unseren Partnern sehr
dankbar die uns unterstützen und das ist
zum Glück praktisch die ganze
demokratische Welt aber ja es gibt
Länder die dabei die Federführung haben
die vorangehen das sind zweifelsohne die
Vereinigten Staaten sie waren immer
wieder Vorbild und andere Länder sind
ihnen gefolgt
Präsident
der Vereinigten Staaten in ein Land
gekommen ist wo Krieg geführt wird das
ist historisch ein Präzedenzfall aber
wir Ukrainer brauchten diese
Unterstützung und diese Geste so sehr
gerade an diesen Tagen der Anspannung
kurz vor dem Jahrestag am 24 Februar
viele fragen sich gerade gegenseitig
bist du in der Ukraine wo bist du am 24
Februar bleibst du oder fährst du weg
denn viele Menschen haben Angst aber die
meisten bleiben da und gehen ihrem
Alltagsleben nach sie gehen zur Arbeit
kümmern sich um ihre Kinder führen ihr
Leben weiter obwohl wir alle angespannt
sind
ja alle fragen sich was die Russen am 24
machen werden
das ist ein Rätsel und niemand weiß was
sie vorhaben mein munkelt dass sie
solche historischen Daten eine große
Bedeutung bei Messen und irgendetwas
symbolisches planen
wir können nur abwarten und uns auf
alles Mögliche gefasst machen
Zusammenhang zum Beispiel mit dem Besuch
eines amerikanischen Präsidenten seine
große Rolle spielt ich sehe Kinder die
sich daran gewöhnt haben in
Luftschutzkeller zu gehen zum Beispiel
ich habe gestern eine Frau getroffen die
mir erzählte was sie für grausame Dinge
erlebt hatte in Europe zu weinen und ich
frag mich ob das Land genügend um die
Menschen in dem Land genügend
psychologische Unterstützung bekommen
das ist eine riesen Aufgabe und
Herausforderung gerade auch für Soldaten
die an der Front sind die da furchtbares
tun und furchtbares sehen und die daran
gewöhnt sind starke Kerle sein zu müssen
aber eigentlich bräuchten sie ja alle
hILFE Kann man da etwas tun ist das ein
Thema über das in der Ukraine geredet
wird und dass sie sich auch kümmern
daran arbeiten wir auch für Militär
Angehörige gibt es bereits solche
internationalen Kooperationen mit
Fachleuten für psychologische
Rehabilitation
[Musik]
da arbeiten wir zum Beispiel mit Israel
zusammen das sehr viel Erfahrung in
diesem Bereich hat wegen des permanenten
militärischen Konflikts dort
dabei geht es sowohl um Soldaten während
sie an der Frontlinie sind als auch um
die Zeit danach wenn sie zurückkehren
posttraumatische Störungen können einen
leider auch erst ein Dutzend Jahre
danach einholen
klar die Soldaten sind starke Männer sie
sind es nicht gewohnt über ihre inneren
Schmerzen zu sprechen das ist in der
Ukraine noch nicht so üblich wir wollen
dieses Tabu aufbrechen wir kämpfen gegen
dieses gesellschaftliches Stigma
wir bemühen uns darum dass man sagen
kann was einem weh tut dass man von
Albträumen geplagt wird dass man nicht
mehr ins normale Leben zurückfindet das
verlangt einem auch viel Mut ab man hat
so viel Mut an der Front bewiesen aber
nun muss man einen weiteren Schritt tun
damit man sich wieder eingliedert
ein bisschen Freundchen viele Soldaten
haben es tatsächlich sehr schwer nach
dem Krieg in die Normalität
zurückzukehren das ist eine
Herausforderung die unsere Gesellschaft
noch lange beschäftigen wird
den ganzen Land Spuren hinterlassen und
Wunden geschlagen und sieht das auch in
den Gesichtern der Menschen was sie
erlebt haben man sieht es aber auch im
Gesicht ihres Ehemanns Präsidenten der
sich sehr verändert hat im Vergleich von
zu vor einem Jahr wie nehmen sie das war
ich denke das ist natürlich das all das
Spuren in einem Menschen hinterlässt und
auch in seinem Gesicht
nach solch einem stressigen Jahren
da kann man nicht derselbe bleiben und
das sehe ich natürlich auch die Falten
die um die Augen bekommen hat dass er
müde aussieht aber ich weiß wie stark er
ist und unterstütze ihn zumindest
manchmal denke ich auch daran zurück wie
er vor drei Jahren war natürlich sehe
ich auch wie sehr er sich verändert hat
dass er gealtert ist aber dann frage ich
mich ob mich das traurig macht und meine
Antwort ist nein
markiert einen Lebensabschnitt in dem er
einen Sieg errungen hat
stolz auf ihre Falten es sind
Erinnerungen und ein vieles kann er auch
mit Dankbarkeit zurückdenken
Anja das überall in der Ukraine Wunden
geschlagen und sich in Gesichter
eingegraben hat
jeder mit dem man hier spricht sagt dass
das eigentlich nicht zu fassen ist dass
dieser Krieg jetzt schon so lange dauert
und das schlimme ist ja dass ein Ende
nicht absehbar ist dass diese Zermürbung
im Alltag weitergeht Christian von
Rechenberg blickt auf ein Land im
ständigen Ausnahmezustand
ein Jahr Krieg hat die Ukraine verändert
an so vielen Stellen durchlöchert
verbrannt unbewohnbar geworden kein
Wasser kein Strom jeder Dritte ohne
Arbeit welche lebt und überlebt musste
sein altes Leben tauschen gegen ein
neues ein kriegsleben voll Schmerz und
Entbehrung und doch mit Aussicht auf
eine andere eine bessere Zukunft aber
wenn man die Ukraine vorher kannte dann
weiß man dass dieser Staat auch jetzt
keine keine Schweiz war die alles für
ihre Bürger geleistet hat und trotzdem
haben diese Menschen sofort entschieden
dass sie alles wirklich alles für diesen
Staat machen werden
anpacken aufräumen das ganze Land ist
mobilisiert vom Bürger bis zum
Bürgermeister mit jedem gespendeten
Essen jedem Trost jedem wieder
aufgebauten Haus wächst das Bewusstsein
einer neuen Gemeinschaft
jeder und jeder ist damit beschäftigt
das Land zu verteidigen und ich denke
dass dieses
Zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl dass dadurch
entsteht das wird auch nach dem Krieg
bleiben
Alexander aus grammathorst der seinen
angelclub öffnete damit hier Kinder ein
paar sorglose Stunden verbringen können
ich bleibe hier weil so viele Menschen
meine Hilfe brauchen jemand muss diese
Arbeit machen also mache ich sie
und auch Valerie der als Freiwilliger
der Armee hinter der Fronten Menschen
wie Tatjana beim Wiederaufbau hilft und
nicht nur dabei
noch wichtiger als dieses Haus wäre mir
ein Grabstein für meinen Sohn
Veränderung auch der Präsident ist nach
einem Jahr Krieg ein anderer
[Musik]
die Möglichkeit gegeben zu zeigen wie
mutig er ist und er ist unglaublich
mutig er ist nicht geflohen obwohl er
das hätte tun können am anderen zu
Beginn des Krieges Alex der Abgeordnete
ist auch nicht geflohen er bringt
Ausrüstung an die Front und Trinkwasser
für die durstige Bevölkerung Mut Courage
das alles zeigt Wirkung
unser Bild von Politikern hat sich
während des Krieges verändert sie haben
angefangen wirklich für uns da zu sein
das sehen wir jetzt klar und deutlich
das Bild von Russland ist für
Generationen beschädigt die grolltaten
von Butscher oder irpin bleiben in
Erinnerung der Mord an der Bevölkerung
er hat System knapp acht Millionen
Menschen fliehen Richtung Westen
Richtung Europa und viele wollen dort
bleiben für immer experten schätzen
jedoch die meisten wollen zurück
Menschen die Familie litovic Sohn und
Mutter heimgekehrt aus Deutschland nach
Odessa ein neues Leben wollen sie
aufbauen und sagen sie gemeinsam der
Angst setzen sie Entschlossenheit
entgegen und Humor
ihr solltet in die Ukraine kommen da
würdet ihr erleben wie man ohne Angst
lebt
Putin wollte Veränderung zum Schlechten
erreicht hatte aber auch das Gegenteil
sein Überfall hat die Ukraine
zusammenwachsen lassen ein Neues
staatsgefühl geschaffen das stärker ist
als je zuvor
und Putin hat noch etwas erreicht dass
das sogenannte Bruder Volk nur noch Hass
empfindet dass ich auch solche Ukraine
abgewendet haben die sich den Russen
zuvor nahe fühlten vor allem im Osten
des Landes das jetzt am schlimmsten
zerstört wird
ob das die Russen bewegt ob ihm das
überhaupt bewusst ist lässt sich schwer
beurteilen frei reden kann man in
putinstiktatur ja nicht mehr sicher ist
aber dass dieser Krieg keineswegs nur
Putins Kriege ist das seine Verachtung
und seinen imperialistischer Anspruch in
seiner Bevölkerung Widerhall findet
der Tag heute in Moskau verlief
berichtet für
am heutigen Tag des Vaterland
Verteidigers Erd Russland seine Soldaten
der Präsident besucht allerdings nicht
etwa seine Truppen im Don Bass oder auf
einem Trainingsgelände sondern richtet
in Moskau hier ein Schleifchen legt dort
Blumen nieder und verspricht
eine effiziente Armee und flotte sind
die Garantien für die Sicherheit und
Souveränität unseres Landes für seine
Entwicklung und Zukunft daher werden wir
wie bisher unsere Verteidigungsfähigkeit
stärken
dass das russische militärunterstützung
braucht ist diesen Anhänger der
Kommunistischen Partei längst klar sie
haben Unterwäsche genäht Nudeln gekauft
und sogar Drohnen gebaut
chinesischen Kameraden werden die
Videokommunikation und Motorsteuerung
liefern alles andere kommt von uns die
Fracht fährt Wladimir piliovin in den
Donbass eine Tour die er schon oft
gemacht hat damit neu Russland
Wirklichkeit wird wie er sagt
wir haben keine Wahl es muss mit einem
Sieg enden wir haben die Worte unseres
Präsidenten gefallen als er sagte wozu
brauchen wir eine Welt in der es kein
Russland gibt
die Grünen Unterstützer der sogenannten
Militäroperation auf der einen Seite auf
der anderen oft gezwungenermaßen im
Ausland die Kritiker des Präsidenten und
dazwischen die große schweigende
Mehrheit der Russinnen und Russen
ein Gefühl des Untergangs hat die
Gesellschaft erfasst die Gesellschaft
für viele in Apathie ist jetzt
unpolitisch es ist sehr klar dass eine
glänzende Zukunft sehr unwahrscheinlich
ist
durchhalten weitermachen darauf schwört
Vladimir Putin Russland ein auch heute
wieder
die Wahrheit ist auf unserer Seite wenn
ich mir euch so anschaue möchte ich
hinzufügen die Zukunft gehört definitiv
uns zu Vladimir Putins Wahrheit gehört
dass er von seinem Volk uneingeschränkte
Opferbereitschaft fordert wer sich
wieder setzt wird ausgegrenzt bedroht
verjagt vor allem das ist Putins
Wahrheit
zu russlandskrieg gegen die Ukraine hat
sich Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz heute
ausführlich geäußert und damit beginnt
Hanna Zimmermann jetzt in Mainz die
Nachrichten
im Interview mit Maybrit Illner
verteidigte Scholz die kriegs-
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger unseres
Landes können sich darauf verlassen dass
ich mich nicht kirre machen lassen werde
von all den vielen Interviews von den
öffentlichen aufrufungen von den
Erklärungen sondern dass es gut
vorbereitete wohl abgestimmte und wohl
abgewogene Entscheidung bleiben das ist
in einer solchen Situation etwas dass
man von einem Regierungschef erwarten
hat
die unfallversammlung hat eine
Resolution verabschiedet die ein Ende
des Krieges in der Ukraine und den
Rückzug Russlands fordert 141 der 193
Länder rotierten für die Resolution
Russland und Belarus stimmten unter
anderem dagegen 32 Länder darunter auch
China enthielten sich damit kann die
Abstimmung an die Ergebnisse vergangener
Ukraine Resolutionen anknüpfen
der Konflikt zwischen Israelis und
Palästinensern verschärft sich weiter
nachdem gestern bei einem israelischen
Militäreinsatz im Westjordanland laut
palästinensischen Angaben mindestens 11
Palästinenser getötet und mehr als 100
verletzt worden sind in der Nacht
feuerten militante Palästinenser
daraufhin mehrere Raketen auf Israel ab
kurz danach griff das israelische
Militär Ziele im Palästinenser Gebiet an
im Tarifstreit des öffentlichen Dienstes
haben Bund und Kommunen ein erstes
Angebot vorgelegt so bieten die
Arbeitgeber eine Lohnerhöhung von
insgesamt fünf Prozent in zwei Schritten
und eine Einmalzahlung von 2500 Euro
zudem soll das Weihnachtsgeld angehoben
werden die Gewerkschaften lehnten das
Angebot ab sie fordern 10,5% mehr Lohn
mindestens aber einen monatliches Plus
von 500 Euro
. die Wetteraussichten morgen von Norden
her Regen der nachmittags die Mitte
erreicht oberhalb von etwa 400 Metern
Schnee im Süden anfangs etwas Sonne
später auch hier Regen 2 bis 13 Grad am
Wochenende vor allem im Osten und Süden
Schneeschauer am Montag viel Sonne bei
-1 bis plus 6 Grad
und wir melden uns noch mal aus Kiel am
Vorabend dieses Jahrestags s wohl noch
nie wurde aus einem Krieg so viel live
berichtet konnte man über Social Media
quasi in echt Zeit das Geschehen
verfolgen die Ukrainer kommunizieren
permanent untereinander und mit der
Außenwelt und haben sich dabei als
Meister moderner Kommunikationsformen
erwiesen gekämpft wird auch im Internet
mit Bildern
die um die Welt gingen viele dienen den
Ukrainern auch dazu sich gegenseitig Mut
zu machen daran über den Krieg im Netz
ein altes partisanenlied Antike lignook
singt das ukrainischer Superstar jetzt
Soldat es wurde zur Hymne in den
sozialen Medien millionenfach angehört
und beliebt als Untermalung von selbst
getreten Videos über den Widerstand der
Ukraine
sie geben Hoffnung
einer dieser Ukraine
57 Jahre alt schulpferdner eine junge
Frau filmte wie er sich russischen
Panzern entgegen stellte mitten auf dem
Dorfplatz genau dort treffen wir ihn
ich hatte keine Angst es war mir egal
als er auf mich zielte habe ich ihm
gesagt schieß doch wenn es dir hilft und
ich stand einfach da ja sagte erschieß
mich
als der russische Panzerfahrer
tatsächlich weiter vor überkam ihn Wut
stolz die Russen waren wie sie gelacht
haben ihre Maschinengewehre gezeigt
haben es hat mich angekotzt ich nahm
mein Fahrrad und habe es auf dem Panzer
geworfen er ist drüber gefahren
der alte Mann und sein Fahrrad das Video
ging um die Welt
Serge erfuhr von seinem Ruhm erst von
Freunden im Dorfladen die russischen
Panzer konnte er nicht aufhalten aber
ein Zeichen des Widerstands hat er
gesetzt es ist der erste Krieg in dem
Helden wie grollt hatten fast in
Echtzeit ihre Öffentlichkeit finden
[Musik]
das war es im heute journal gegen 0:35
Uhr meldet sich Wulf schmiese mit dem
heutigen Update auch hier aus Kiew und
morgen am Jahrestag selbst wollen wir
auch von hier aus senden wenn die Lage
ist zulässt notfalls aus dem Keller
insofern sage ich wir sehen uns morgen
wieder und gebe jetzt ab wann Maybrit
Illner die ihr heute den Bundeskanzler
zu Gast hat auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]